[Music]
okay in our peachy's way over the top
well better be careful you don't want
the best things in your life to happen
to your alter ego right now my alter ego
is on a helicopter about to die only the
goose sorry miss Lowenthal I will
publish your book it just felt so real
nonfiction true memoirs of an
international assassin you said you
wouldn't change a word I didn't abandon
order people sick legged man maybe they
do maybe they do the whole assassin
thing it's BS right well I could tell
you but then I'd have to slit your
throat and watch you bleed out I didn't
yours want to kill the president
how Monsieur you got the wrong guy
move on cupcake
what an actual assassin write a book
about being an assassin it's beyond
stupid I'm gonna get you out of this or
is it so beyond stupid it's brilliant he
might actually be the real deal
where is he no look at it I didn't
imagine you to be a bit you know longer
[Applause]
you are not the ghost oh maybe I am the
ghost now we gotta get you out of here
missions on mission it's not boring the
ghost doesn't just walk away
never bring a knife to a ghost
ah ah you brought a knife to a gunfight
Thank You ghost how about a break your
finger if you ever shushing me again
about my knuckle there
the love of her life nope lemmings are
in the house yeah oh my god
well looks like he barks out quite a
step you get him up here please p-please